m bellemare et son client et ricard
peintes ou de rentrer dans une salle la
cour d'appel de fort-de-france bien
gardés pour cause de huis clos seuls les
avocats et leurs clients peuvent y
rentrer ce matin les avocats qui
défendent les trois mis en examen dans
la sphère du sert et demi à m riwal
rosiers sénart et bellemare ont plaidé
devant les magistrats de la chambre du
conseil
ce qu'il souhaite c'est que le contrôle
judiciaire imposé à fred célimène qu'un
vil au goût c'est évident car peint
depuis janvier 2016 soit levée et
pourquoi parce que le 8 novembre dernier
à paris
le conseil d'état a annulé le
licenciement de messieurs logos à
s'éliminer karpin et la levée du
contrôle judiciaire permettrait donc à
ces trois professeurs de regagner leur
poste à l'université des antilles et
devant les magistrats le nouvel avocat
de l'université aurait plaidé pour
l'apaisement et nous assistons là à un
changement total d'orientation de l'ua
dans cette affaire de là à dire que
cette institution souhaite le retour des
trois professeurs en son sein c'est un
pas que nous ne franchirons pas mais
cela y ressemble fortement
il ya un retournement de la part de
l'université on peut pas parler de
retournement
il y a simplement une sérénité nouvelle
une clarté une objectivité une science
que nous essayons d'appliquer aussi dans
les débats n'est ce pas je pense que
auparavant il y avait beaucoup de
patients un problème posé avec plus de
sérénité entraîne forcément un résultat
aussi incontestable c'est surtout cela
qui nous importe ce n'est pas un
changement de 2
vision puisque comme je les ai indiqué
tout à l'heure nous laissons la chambre
de l'instruction nous ne rapportons aux
décisions de la chambre de l'instruction
et nous restons toujours partie civile
mais nous voulons que les outils
utilisés soient les outils les plus
loyaux possible parce que plus ils
seront loyaux mois ci seront contestées
les avocats des trois mis en examen dans
cette affaire du séga demi en refusé
toute interview
mais qu'un vil logo ça a tenu à nous
expliquer qu'il a été mis en examen en
2016 sans jamais avoir été mis en garde
à vue et sans jamais avoir été convoqué
chez un magistrat on pourrait donc
s'attendre je dis bien on pourrait
s'attendre à ce que les magistrats lève
le contrôle judiciaire à l'encontre de
monsieur logos à célimène et karpin et
si ce contrôle judiciaire élevé cela
permettrait à ces trois mis en examen de
retrouver le chemin de l'université
universités où ils sont tous les trois
professeurs réponse donc le 13 mars
prochain on saura donc si les magistrats
ont décidé ou pas de lever ce contrôle
judiciaire à l'encontre de ces trois mis
en examen